bonjour guettant marengo merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
arte france une plainte contre
jean-michel blanquer air est elle
justifiée alors que probablement les
écoles vont fermer la semaine prochaine
est ce que vous êtes satisfait si cette
mesure se confirme
la plainte est basé sur quoi exactement
bonjour donc la plainte est basé comme
vous venez de le dire sur la mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui parce que nous
membres des stylos rouges nous estimons
que la sécurité des personnels des
élèves de leur famille n'est pas
garantie par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui depuis un an ne cesse de
minimiser la gravité de la situation et
ne cesse de communiquer pour faire
penser que tout va bien dans les écoles
alors qu'on sait que c'est pas du tout
le cas alors le pour le gouvernement la
fermeture des écoles
elle a pour conséquence la rupture du
lien social pour les élèves la mise sur
la touche 1 pour certains enfants
notamment dans les zones les plus
difficiles
qu'est ce que vous répondez à cet
argument en fait nous partageons
exactement le même constat il n'a jamais
été question pour les professeurs dans
les écoles et les lycées de fermer les
établissements scolaires nous ce qu'on
réclamait à l'origine c'était des
mesures concrètes pour protéger tout le
monde et garantir justement cet
enseignement
or on déplore le fait que nous ne sommes
pas protégés
le nombre de cas augmente sans arrêt
nous allons au travail la peur au ventre
et malheureusement il semblerait que on
s'achemine vers des fermetures de plus
en plus importante de classe alors que
c'est ce qu'on voulait éviter aux de
prime abord cette fermeture
cette semaine
à ce jour en tout cas eu un cas confirmé
une classe fermée pour vous c'est passé
pas satisfaisant c'est la mesure qu'a
préconisé jean michel blanc coeur pour
l'instant non le problème madame c'est
que cette mesure
elle survient bien trop tard et puis
elle repose sur du déclaratif notamment
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait que les
parents d'élèves déclare
systématiquement le fait que leurs
enfants soient malades
déjà on a constaté récemment que
bizarrement le nombre d'enfants malades
semblerait baissé parce que certains
parents craindrait de déclarer que leur
enfant est malade parce qu'il porterait
la responsabilité de la fermeture des
classes notamment dans le primaire et
puis d'autre part ça supposerait que il
y ait des tests systématiques dans les
écoles or on sait que ce n'est pas le
cas dans les collèges et les lycées par
exemple c'est très très peu répandue en
plus ce sont des tests rhinopharyngées
relativement dissuasif pour les jeunes à
titre d'exemple dans mon établissement
c'est à peu près 5% des élèves qui ont
été testées depuis le début vous voyez
bien que lorsqu'on dit qu'on va fermer
une classe
dès qu'il ya un cas encore faudrait-il
qu'on soit capable de détecter ce cas ce
qui est pas du tout cela aujourd'hui le
gouvernement qui mise aussi sur la
vaccination massive des des enseignants
dans les prochaines semaines
ça aussi c'est quelque chose que vous
réclamiez bien sûr les professeurs
réclament depuis le début d'être pris en
compte parce qu'ils se savent très
exposé on sait bien que le protocole
sanitaire a été allégé trois fois qu'il
ne s'applique que dans la mesure du
possible donc autant dire qu'il
s'applique pas vraiment ou alors ils
s'appliquent pas partout pareil
vous savez très bien qu'on peut pas
forcément ouvrir les fenêtres dans les
salles de classe pour des raisons
évidentes de sécurité
vous le savez qu'on a traversé l'hiver
vous pensez bien que faire classe avec
des fenêtres ouvertes régulièrement à 15
degrés
c'est pas l'idéal est de fait
effectivement nous nous réclamions
depuis le début une vaccination
nous souhaitions être publics
prioritaires maintenant le président de
la république a déclaré qu on
les être vaccinés dès la mi-avril
bon ce sont encore des déclarations nous
ça fait un an qu'on attend des actes
alors c'est vrai qu'il y a en moyenne
30% de deux cas en plus de contamination
dans les lycées notamment vous pensez
que jean michel blanquer a menti
sciemment jusqu'ici en tout cas jusqu'à
ce qu'il reconnaisse qu'il y avait des
contaminations dans les écoles pour à
tout prix les maintenir ouvertes en tout
cas ce que l'on considère c'est que
monsieur blanc caire et dans un
véritable déni
il semble faire mine d'ignorer que la
charge virale chez les enfants est la
même que chez les adultes
il fait mine d'ignorer que les enfants
transmettent le virus qu'ils se sont
comment dirais-je partager à l'école et
qui le ramène dans les familles il est
peut-être pas nécessaire de rappeler qu'
il ya des élèves qui ont perdu leurs
parents du fait du coronavirus que la
situation est très grave que
contrairement à ce que le gouvernement
prétend il n'y a pas de demi jauge selon
son expression dans tous les
établissements dans certains
établissements d'ailleurs ont fait cours
en classe entière à plus de 35 dans
quarante mètres carrés et évidemment
nous nous pensons que monsieur blanc
caire et dans un véritable déni et
d'ailleurs on comprend pas tellement
parce que monsieur blanc caire prétend
vouloir maintenir les écoles ouvertes et
en même temps force est de constater
qu'il n'y met pas du tout les moyens
merci gaëtan marengo d'avoir répondu à
nos questions ce matin je le rappelle
vous êtes membre des styles rouge
professeur d'histoire géographie